à celles ci des mois je m'en souvenais
la mère de sécurité attribué au passage
la réduction des coûts à la figer à
bonal j'ai simplement je me demandais ce
que je faisais là
je vends mes enfants je me souviens la
première journée à la maternelle
nous devons parler de ça et je regardais
les amoureux avec leur foi leur façon
dans la facilité par 2,5 alors que moi
chacun des cinq réseaux table avec une
page même une tâche ou alors c'était ma
façon je l'aimais japon les années se
sont écoulées
je me souvienne je m'étais assise
toujours toujours en avance pour voir ce
grave moi parfois il était par ceux qui
les retiennent je voulais apprendre car
j'avais une curieuse c'est leur élection
la fin du contenu
lorsqu'on était suspendre le professeur
simon ça je n'ai repris avec des femmes
car je ne savais jamais convaincu c'est
être présent pendant des années j'ai
compris que je devais celle ci en
arrière tout près du mur et je ferai mon
public je le plaçait derrière une
personne afin que l'enseignant ne voit
pas et n'ont malheureusement la question
de prix
réellement lancer de se lever la tête
avant que je souhaitais à koudougou et
dans la tête des enfants
je ne comprenais points contre la
transhumance c'est faux j'avais jamais
la bonne pour moi croyez le ou non
croyants j'ai voulu mon second terrain
au michigan nord pour réfléchir car à
l'époque j'avais pourtant une fois pour
mémoire moi mais moi dans l'euro
les peines et les connexions neuronales
que je peux enfin 24 ans je me mange
entend ce que je faisais japon tête tous
avec moi falashas gagner du terrain jeu
télévisé auquel m
la revue le contenu porte moi je disais
c'est jeu vers l'avant
je ne comprenais crois qu'on va contre
ses démons femme aura valu par
l'industrie de ne plus penser en classe
difficultés de concentration
je ne pensais qu'à ma chute à
l'infirmière dammarie parce que avec du
vieux si j'avais fait ça
vous savez les cours d'école souvent je
balance se forment des équipes gay moi
je n'ai joué au ballon mais passons
je ne comprenais pas toujours les règles
du jeu à fond alors que moi
la phalange le mettait dans mon groupe
entend cette époque là on ne le met pas
ce fut sa caméra comme parcours soit
détachée j'ai quand même terminé mon
secondaire 5 élan suite car c'est sûr
mais ça m'a laissé des cicatrices a fait
la différence
enfin qu'une personne a sous sa garde
mais malgré tout cela je suis capable je
crois qu'on l'a pensé à moi je n'en a
pas voulu
la france ne font que je vais partager
avec vous ce pansement et les mémoires
et ce fait la différence
l'illusion d'être enterrée soi même
de par sa forme j'aime apprendre qu'elle
soit par des réseaux wan gars le soir
coloris bleu rose va je suis unique par
cette forme que j'appelle la fois la
forme sera dans une petite poêle et y
avait dans ses cheveux
cette forme j'aimerais vous irez plâtre
une deux avec nuance accepter la
différence ce sont deux succès pour
regarder à venir
france et leur fit escale à la france
d'une musique en ligne